MIDTERMS ARE ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
WHO IS IN OFFICE BUT JOE BIDEN,
PRESIDENT BIDEN WANTS TO MAKE IT
ABOUT HIS PREDECESSOR.
LAST NIGHT DONALD TRUMP WAS ALSO
IN THE KEYSTONE STATE.
IT WAS HIS FIRST CAMPAIGN TRAIL
APPEARANCE SINCE DOZENS OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WERE
RECOVERED FROM HIS MAR-A-LAGO
HOME.
WHAT WAS MEANT TO BE A RALLY FOR
A COUPLE OF CANDIDATES WAS A
MAGA-PHONE ON ATTACKS FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> HE'S AN ENEMY OF THE STATE IF
YOU WANT TO NOPE THE TRUTH.
THE ENEMY OF THE STATE IS HIM
AND THE GROUP THAT CONTROL HIM.
THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAVE BECOME VICIOUS
MONSTERS CONTROLLED BY RADICAL
LEFT SSCOUNDRELS, LAWYERS AND TE
MEDIA WHO TELL THEM WHAT TO DO.
>> I'M JOINED NOW BY
CONGRESSWOMAN ZOE LOFGREN.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING TIME FOR US
ON A HOLIDAY WEEKEND.
YOU HAVE THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES CALLING THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AN ENEMY OF THE STATE.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> WELL, IT'S BIZARRE.
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN DID CAUTION
AMERICANS ABOUT EXTREMISM IN HIS
SPEECH IN PHILADELPHIA.
AND THE EX-PRESIDENT IS PROVING
HIS CASE TO CALL OUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS VICIOUS ENEMIES.
I UNDERSTAND THAT HE IDENTIFIED
AN FBI AGENT BY NAME ON HIS
SOCIAL MEDIA, PROBABLY EXPOSING
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL TO
THREATS THAT WE'VE SEEN.
IT'S JUST WEIRD AND, YOU KNOW,
THAT HE MAKES EVERYTHING ABOUT
HIMSELF.
THE REPUBLICAN VOTERS I KNOW
HERE IN MY DISTRICT, THEY DIDN'T
STEAL CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND
PUT THEM IN A LITTLE ROOM OFF
THEIR POOL.
THE EX-PRESIDENT DID THAT.
IT'S A WEIRD SPEECH.
>> HE ALSO REFERRED TO MEMBERS
OF THE FBI THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, AS VICIOUS MONSTERS,
QUOTE, UNQUOTE, VICIOUS
MONSTERS.
YOU LOOKED AT, ALONG WITH THE
COMMITTEE, TRUMP'S RHETORIC
LEADING UP TO JANUARY 6th.
DO YOU THINK THAT KIND OF
RHETORIC IS MORE INCITEMENT?
>> WELL, POTENTIALLY, YES.
IN THE LEADUP TO JANUARY 6 THERE
WERE EXTRAVAGANT CLAIMS MADE
MEANT TO INFLAME PUBLIC OPINION
AND THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE ALTHOUGH I THINK IT'S MEANT
TO TURN PEOPLE AGAINST LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND WE'VE
SEEN THAT SOMETIMES THAT
RHETORIC REACHES PEOPLE WHO ARE
PREPARED TO ACT ON IT, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE FELLOW WHO WAS
KILLED WHEN HE TRIED TO ATTACK
THE FBI AGENTS IN OHIO.
THIS IS NOT RESPONSIBLE.
AND THE EX-PRESIDENT OUGHT TO
STOP IT.
MEAN WHILE, ALL OF US, DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS, IN ELECTED
OFFICE, SHOULD CALL THIS OUT.
THIS IS NOT PROPER BEHAVIOR.
>> AND ONE OF THE RALLY SPEAKERS
WAS SOMEBODY NAMED CYNTHIA
HUGHES.
SHE RUNS A GROUP THAT RAISES
MONEY FOR JANUARY 6 DEFENDANTS.
OUR MARSHALL COHEN POINTS OUT
LAST NIGHT SHE TOLD A STORY TO
GET SYMPATHY FOR HER NEPHEW WHO
IS A CONVICTED CAPITOL
INSURRECTIONIST AND THIS IS HER
NEPHEW HERE POSING AS ADOLF
HITLER.
HIS FORMER COLLEAGUES TESTIFIED
HE SAID, QUOTE, HITLER SHOULD
HAVE FINISHED THE JOB.
HE WAS CONVICTED ON ALL FIVE
CHARGES HE FACED.
DO YOU THINK THIS BELONGS AT ANY
KIND OF A POLITICAL RALLY, THIS
KIND OF SPEAKER GIVEN THIS SORT
OF PLATFORM?
>> WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN WARNED
THERE ARE SOME ELEMENTS IN THIS
EXTREME GROUP THAT ARE
SEMIFASCIST, MAYBE HE DIDN'T
NEED TO USE SEMI.
BEING A SUPPORTER OF ADOLF
HITLER DOES PUT YOU IN THE
FASCIST CATEGORY.
THERE'S NO SEMI ABOUT IT.
I DO THINK THIS IS TROUBLING.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE SHOULDN'T
STAND UP FOR PEACEFUL
COMMUNITIES TO PUSH BACK AGAINST
THE CHAOS THAT THE EX-PRESIDENT
IS TRYING TO CREATE.
WE OUGHT TO BE THANKFUL TO OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY THAT
TRIES TO DO THEIR BEST TO KEEP
US SAFE INSTEAD OF ATTACKING
THEM.
>> WE'RE STILL LEARNING ABOUT
THE SCALE OF THE SENSITIVE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE DISCOVERED
AT MAR-A-LAGO.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I HAD, AND
PERHAPS YOU CAN ANSWER IT, IS IT
POSSIBLE ANY OF THESE DOCUMENTS
WERE IN ANY WAY CONNECTED TO THE
JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION?
MIGHT THEY HAVE -- MIGHT THEY BE
OF SOME INTEREST TO THE JANUARY
6th INVESTIGATION?
>> WE DON'T KNOW YET.
HERE IS WHAT WE ARE DOING.
WE ASKED THE ARCHIVES FOR A
WHOLE SET OF MATERIAL AND THEY
SENT US WHAT THEY HAD.
THE QUESTION WE HAVE IS SOME OF
WHAT WAS RETURNED ON THE LIST OF
WHAT WE ASKED FOR?
WE DON'T NOPE THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION YET BUT WE EXPECT TO
GET THE ANSWER.
>> AND HOW SOON DO YOU EXPECT TO
GET THAT ANSWER?
>> WELL, THEY'RE WORKING HARD.
MEMBERS ARE WORKING OVER THE
WEEKEND ALONG WITH OUR STAFF.
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO DO AND
LIMITED TIME TO DO IT.
WE ARE PRESSING EVERYONE TO MAKE
THIS A HIGH PRIORITY TO GET
ANSWERS.
AT THIS POINT WE DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION.
>> ONE HEARING IS PLANNED THIS
MONTH.
ANY UPDATE ON WHEN THAT COULD
BE, WHAT IT WOULD COVER, AND
WHEN WILL WE SEE THAT FULL
REPORT?
WILL WE SEE IT BY THE END OF THE
YEAR?
>> I ALWAYS LEAVE THE
ANNOUNCEMENTS UP TO THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR.
I'M NOT ABLE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
BUT SURELY WE WILL HAVE OUR
COMPLETE REPORT DONE BY THE END
OF THIS YEAR.
WE'VE ALWAYS PLANNED ON THAT.
ALL CONGRESSIONAL SELECT
COMMITTEES ARE ESTABLISHED FOR
THE LIFE OF THE CONGRESS.
THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN OUR
INTENTION AND REMAINS SO.
>> HEADING INTO A MID-TERM
POLITICAL CYCLE.
YOUR COLLEAGUES WILL BE RUNNING
FOR RE-ELECTION.
WILL THAT GET IN THE WAY OF
GETTING FINISHED ON TIME?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
THERE'S SUCH A LARGE VOLUME OF
MATERIAL.
WE ARE BUSY WORKING ON IT.
NOT ONLY THAT THE CHARGE OF THE
COMMITTEE WAS NOT JUST TO FIND
THE FACTS AND LAY THEM OUT BUT
TO COME UP WITH POSSIBLE
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES OR
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES.
WE WILL HAVE ALL OF IT DONE BY
THE END OF THE YEA